so l'union qui a été planté en 2000 2002
18 ans à deux semaines des vendanges
petit tour d'inspection pour alison
clément et benoît dumergues ouvrier
viticole pendant une dizaine d'années le
couple réalise son rêve en 2016 en
achetant ce domaine et 9 hectares de
vignes sont alors en friche au taï et et
au sécateur benoît redonne vie à sokoto
exploiter dès le xiiie siècle par les
moines chartreux voisins sap a été
taillée pendant six ans donc il a fallu
reprendre la taille la remettre le roi
des sang de la vigne pour cartes
deviennent fructifères qu'il a fallu
défricher
donc il y avait des ronces il y avait
des armes et la petit à petit on reprend
un peu la culture du sol sous le sous
les 7 pour essayer d'éliminer la
concurrence est là du coup ça va être la
troisième branche qu'on réalise dessus à
la sueur de leur front ces nouveaux
vignerons récolte les fruits de leur
travail depuis 2018
pour l'instant 15 mille bouteilles sont
déjà sortis de leur chef mais il est
bien là seillier et bien sûr la fraise
l'achat du bien ça va donner car siens
leur cuvée 2010 neuf et tout juste
embouteillée car locaux vides 19 à
bloquer leurs commandes de bouteilles et
de bouchons chez leur fournisseur
italien crise sanitaire oblige les
restaurateurs et hôteliers commandes
moins que d'habitude et les salons sont
annulés résultat alors que les vendanges
s'approche les caisses du domaine des
folies douces sont vides on devait faire
notre mise en bouteille au début de
printemps
ça a été pas mal bloqué pour plein de
raisons techniques et puis donc la
commercialisation forcément a été
retardée on commercialise juste là donc
on lan de trésorerie
donc là on lance une campagne de pré
vente de bouteilles du millésime 2010 9
sur la plateforme de financement
participatif mimosas pour payer
vendangeurs et matérielles le couple
aurait besoin de 10000 euros
ils en ont déjà récolté plus de 3000